Have you ever wondered why people act the way they do? Do you want to know why we get angry, sad, happy?
Psychology can offer answers and insights into how we act and why we feel how we do
Do you want to learn some really exciting and surprising pyschological
findings? If you do, watch on for nine very interesting psychological facts that you may not know about
Number 1:
People who speak two or more languages may change their personalities between languages without even knowing it
So someone may become more introverted when speaking French, or more agreeable when speaking German
Number 2:
People are more likely to follow orders in unfamiliar settings. This is because we're more likely to be obedient when we're unsure
or when we feel others have more knowledge than us
So if you want someone to do something with you, like go on a trip, maybe ask them in an unfamiliar environment
Number 3: Even those who are concerned with equality, holds implicit bias about things such as race
This is due to something known as the out-group bias, where we implicitly trust those who aren't a part of our in-group plus
It is important to remember that this is implicit?
Meaning it is not consciously controlled
Number 4:
Eye contact makes us more resistant to persuasion
This seems to be because eye contact is related to dominance- something we resent when someone is trying to persuade us to change our minds
so when you're trying to convince someone to buy something or to go to the cinema with you,
eye contact might not be good
Number 5:
The actor-observer bias is a tendency for us to blame our behavior on situational factors
But blame other people's behaviors on internal factors
For example, we may blame our own bad mood on getting stuck in traffic
Why we would blame others bad mood on the personality
It's important we don't just make exceptions for ourselves
So try to be open-minded towards others when working out why they haven't acted a certain way
Number 6: women who give birth to boys are more likely to develop postnatal depression
Myers and John's finding could be helpful in identifying those at risk of postnatal depression and giving them extra support
Number 7:
social media usage increases depression and loneliness
Huntail found that this was especially true of people who were already depressed
It seems this is a case due to social comparison- comparing your lives to other's lives as seen on social media
So if you find yourself feeling lonely or depressed
Spending a bit less time on social media might be a good idea
Number 8:
Daughters who have close ties with their fathers can overcome loneliness easier
This was only true with daughters
With sons the closest of their relationships with their parents didn't affect how well they overcame loneliness
Yanelle suggested this is because boys aren't socialized to have close bonds and relationships in the same way girls are
Did you enjoy our first series on interesting psychology facts?
If so, comment some interesting facts you know that you would like us to share in our next video
You might even get featured! Be sure to like this video and subscribe to our channel for more psychological content
Subtitles by the fans, for the fans
Check out the new merch down in the description!